- HI, I'M ROMAN.
MY FATHER DR. ARMOND
IS THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
ANIMAL PLASTIC SURGEON
IN LOS ANGELES.
- WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS TAKE IN THE STOMACH.
- HIS FRIENDS LIZ AND LIZ
HELPED HIM
GET HIS OWN REALITY SHOW,
AND THAT REALITY SHOW
DESTROYED HIS MARRIAGE.
- I WANT A DIVORCE.
- ♪ SAY WHAT
- MY DAD MOVED OUT, AND NOW
IT'S JUST ME AND MY MOM.
SO I'M THE MAN OF THE HOUSE,
AND NOW I'M HAVING
THE TIME OF MY LIFE.
- ♪ SAY WHAT
- UH-OH,
C-CZAR, ROMAN.
TAKING,
TAKING OVER THIS JOINT.
- C-CZAR.
- MM.
- YEAH, C-CZAR'S,
LIKE, MY BEST FRIEND.
HE'S, LIKE, COOLER
THAN ALL THE COOL KIDS
AT SCHOOL.
YOU KNOW, HE SMOKES WEED,
HE DRINKS 40s,
HE GOT A LIP RING,
AND HE STEALS STUFF.
- LET'S GET LIFTED.
LET'S GET LIFTED.
- YEAH, BUT LET'S DO IT OUTSIDE,
THOUGH.
WE CAN'T SMOKE
IN HERE, THOUGH.
REMEMBER?
- [bleep] ALREADY LIT, B.
IT'S GONNA SMELL UP
EITHER WAY.
YOUR MOM COMES HOME,
YOU BE LIKE,
"BITCH, I'M THE MAN
OF THE HOUSE NOW.
COOK ME A STEAK,
MEDIUM-RARE."
- YEAH, YEAH, YOU RIGHT.
YEAH, YOU RIGHT.
YOU AIN'T NEVER LIE.
- ROMAN!
ROMAN, ARE YOU SMOKING
IN THIS HOUSE?
- WE'RE JUST--WE AIN'T MESSING
ANYTHING UP.
- AND THERE'S NO SKATEBOARDING
IN THIS HOUSE.
YOU KNOW THAT.
- NOTHING'S GONNA HAPPEN.
- NO CHICKEN NUGGETS
FOR YOU TONIGHT.
- WHY DON'T YOU--
- [gasps]
- OH, SNAP.
- OH.
- NOW WHO'S GONNA CLEAN
THAT UP?
- UM...
YEAH, UM...
I MEAN...
- BITCH, I'M THE MAN
OF THE HOUSE NOW.
COOK ME A STEAK,
MEDIUM-RARE.
- MOM, WHY DON'T YOU
CLEAN IT UP?
- EXCUSE ME?
- COOK ME A STEAK, BITCH.
- OH, NO, ROMAN, YOU DIDN'T JUST
DISRESPECT YOUR MOM LIKE THAT.
- WHY, YOU LITTLE--
GET OVER HERE.
- NO, MOM.
- RIGHT NOW.
- NO! OW!
- SPANKING TIME.
THAT'S RIGHT.
SPANKING TIME.
- AH!
YEAH, I'M SCARED OF YOU, MOM.
I COULD PROBABLY GET YOU KILLED
IF I WANTED TO.
[sobs]
- YOU LOOK GOOD.
- WHO THE HELL ARE YOU?
- I'M C-CZAR.
I DON'T HAVE A MOM.
STRAIGHT UP, I BEEN, HAVE BEEN
WITH OLDER WOMEN BEFORE,
AND YOU LOOK GOOD TO ME.
- THAT'S--THAT'S VERY RUDE.
THAT'S...
- YOU HAVE
A VERY BEAUTIFUL HOME.
- UH.
both: OH, YEAH.
- OH, YOU LIKE THAT?
- OH, YEAH.
[moaning]
- AW, YUCK!
- SIGN MY REPORT CARD.
SIGN MY REPORT CARD.
- YO, YOU SALTY, DAWG.
- SORRY, C-CZAR.
YO, YOU MY SON, SON.
- WHATEVER, DAD.
- COMING UP
ON ROMAN'S EMPIRE...
- I'D LOVE TO FIGURE OUT
SOME WAY TO CHEER UP ROMAN.
- I THINK THAT'S A GREAT IDEA.
- YEAH, MAYBE DAVE & BUSTER'S.
- OH, I LOVE
DAVE & BUSTER'S.
- MM-HMM.
- THEN...
- I KNOW IF I LOVE
DAVE & BUSTER'S,
ROMAN WOULD LOVE
DAVE & BUSTER'S.
- RIGHT. THAT WOULD BE
A GREAT IDEA, SHANNON.